The Wizarding World exists in secret.
That much is made clear early on in the Harry
Potter series, and the conflict that exists
between wizards and non-magic users, known
as Muggles, is a constant focus throughout
all seven of the Harry Potter books, the eight
film adaptations, and the ongoing Fantastic
Beasts film franchise.
However, despite how integral the rift between
the magical and Muggle communities is in the
series, neither the books nor the movies go
all that in depth into the history of the
conflict between the world's magical and non-magical
citizens.
In fact, the Harry Potter series more or less
leaves the details of the relationship between
the muggle and wizarding societies to the
imagination.
The series refers to a handful of real-life
historical events, like the Salem Witch Trials
and the first and second world wars, in passing
from time to time, but it doesn't dive too
deeply into how the wizarding community eventually
achieved the secret existence that it maintains
throughout both franchises.
One popular Harry Potter fan theory, however,
offers up a game-changing explanation for
the relationship between the Muggle and wizarding
communities.
One Reddit user believes that the reason wizards
were forced into hiding is because they lost
a war with the Muggles hundreds of years prior
to the events of the Harry Potter series.
This Redditor speculates that there may have
been a war between wizards and Muggles at
some point during the Middle Ages, and the
Muggles, somehow, emerged as the victors.
That defeat could, therefore, be what led
the wizarding community to not only live in
secret, but also in legitimate fear of Muggles.
It may even explain why the Minister of Magic
must keep the British Prime Minister up to
date on all matters within the Wizarding World.
That is to say that the Minister doesn't necessarily
do it out of courtesy, but because it's been
a requirement ever since the Muggles scored
their decisive victory over wizards centuries
prior.
It's a compelling theory, and one that totally
redefines the perceived power balance between
the wizards and Muggles of the world.
It raised the possibility that Muggles may
have been far more capable of taking on wizards
in the Middle Ages than most Harry Potter
fans would likely assume.
"I was the only one to see her for what she
was: A freak."
If this theory is true, it would certainly
explain some elements of the oddly strained
relationship between Muggles and wizards.
Beyond that, it might also explain why wizards
go to such extreme lengths to hide themselves
from their non-magical brethren.
Throughout the series, readers and audiences
learn that wizards cast spells more or less
constantly to cover their tracks from Muggles,
whether they're hiding entire castles — like
Hogwarts — or dressing in regular Muggle
clothing at the Quidditch World Cup to look
less suspicious.
Even so, wizards take a lot of risks by stationing
important buildings or vital passageways like
the pub that leads to Diagon Alley right in
the middle of London — though they seem
to bank on the fact that Muggles just don't
notice.
"Excuse me sir, can you tell me where I might
find Platform 9 and three quarters?"
As the Knight Bus conductor Stan Shunpike
tells Harry in Prisoner of Azkaban, Muggles
don't see the super-fast, shape-shifting bus
moving at warp speeds throughout London because
they simply aren't paying attention.
There's another element of the wizarding world
that could definitely explain the ongoing
animosity between Muggles and wizards: specifically,
the belief by certain sects of wizards that
Muggleborn wizards are inferior.
Muggleborns — meaning witches and wizards
born to non-magical parents who unexpectedly
show magical abilities — are equally as
powerful as their pureblood brethren, as witches
like Lily Potter and Hermione Granger handily
prove.
However, pureblood purists like Draco Malfoy
often level slurs like "Mudblood" against
their Muggleborn and "half-blood" counterparts.
Don't worry — Hermione gets her revenge
against Draco time and time again.
"Aww."
"Malfoy, you ok?"
This absurd prejudice could be related to
a war in which Muggles bested wizards; perhaps
ancient wizarding families like the Malfoys
are still bitter that their non-magical counterparts
somehow beat them in battle.
Obviously, none of this has ever been confirmed
in the series, but it's always fun to wonder
if, at one point, Muggles scored a huge victory
over a bunch of super-powerful witches.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.